the president's visit to Davos was by
any measure a smashing success
he was adored by the elites he engaged
world leaders on the sidelines and he
delivered a speech that was disciplined
serious and unapologetic I will always
put America first just like the leaders
of other countries should put their
country first also but America first
does not mean America alone the
president delivered a calm and reasoned
defense of economic nationalism while at
the same time showing respect to our
international allies but regardless of
how well the president performs the
media they'll never give him a fair
shake it's really pathetic
here's what some of them thought of the
Davos speech it was quite different in
tone to the more measured I guess what's
the word sedated some people say I have
never seen a lower energy level from him
where being a Content was a victory lap
it was almost I felt like he was almost
gonna fall asleep at some point I was
struck by the lack of Verve and I'd
never seen him more low-energy well had
the president been really animated they
would have said he's yelling he's
shouting he looks angry the ugly
American he sounds like ill duche now we
know this clique of journalists in DC
and New York has never understood the
appeal of Trump they've said he's
unhinged he's ill suited for the
presidency and remember even before
inauguration day they insisted that his
arrogant tone and populist policies
would destroy him and the planet oh they
portray him 24/7 as a dictator in
waiting and a fanatic who demands
loyalty from everyone around him well
that's not what the people in Davos saw
but at least now we see who the true
fanatics are the media themselves
the breaking news a military
dictatorship that appears to be what the
White House thinks the United States is
for the impulses of a tyrant the
impulses of a dictator he attacks the
news institutions which is what Franco
and Hitler and Mussolini and a whole
bunch of other people did the kind of
strategy that what do you have how many
dictators and tyrants have you he's
attacking the press he calls them the
enemy of the people which is rhetoric
that you usually hear from people like
Mao and Stalin yeah they killed like 20
million to 60 million people Mao and
Stalin but that's just the same as Trump
oh my gosh these people are simply
slavish adherence to a world view that
is elitist and they're addicted to
policies that are frankly growing more
unpopular around the world as the days
weeks and months go on and I'll say this
very few of them have the
professionalism to step back for just a
minute and absorb the positive news that
the Trump presidency has actually
created for America now aside from the
rare ABC headline like why aren't more
news organizations heralding the news on
jobs economic growth
soaring consumer confidence the good
news for African Americans Latino
Americans because it works against their
own worldview that's why now think about
it this way imagine if the opposite had
occurred if Trump had presided over an
economic downturn now they would have
said we told you Trump is going to
destroy the world these same reporters
and pundits would have pounced on his
conservative populism and blame Trump
for the derailment of the Obama recovery
it's so transparent no wonder the
media's approval and the ratings keep
falling but I'll tell you this the media
aren't the only rabid fanatics that
Trump and his agenda have exposed just
look at the reaction over the past 24
hours to the president's immigration
reform and daca plan now last week
remember he was set to offer 800,000
daca recipients amnesty in exchange for
border security at end of chain
migration these all
etc well the Democrats rejected that
deal and they shut down the government
it blew up in Chuck Schumer's face so
this week after working with a broad
group of senators the president has
widened in the amnesty pool to 1.8
million illegal immigrants that's a
million jump now this move truth be told
has agitated the president's base quite
a bit their opinions were expressed on
my radio show today and they were
overwhelmingly critical if Trump goes
through with this like this he could
very well lose my vote in 2020 if he
does that he sees his Canadian political
suicide
not only it can demoralize his base he's
also gonna make the Republican Party Act
if he continues to pursue this he's
clearly lost me as a voter I I don't see
the difference between him and Obama I
did not vote for time for him to do this
and I will not vote for him again if he
does that that's interesting do you
notice there were a number of Hispanic
voters in that montage that we've just
put together fascinating now everyone
knows that this is not the plan that I
was hoping for and certainly not the one
that I think Republicans in the Senate
should agree to but what's happening is
the president is taking this risky
gambit in an effort to finally get
common-sense immigration controls in
place and what he's thinking I believe
is that we have to end this massive
influx of immigrants into the United
States who are admitted without regard
for need or merit what they're going to
bring to the country and we also must
stop the wave of humanity illegal
immigrants busting across our southern
border every year only to stay for
however long they want now like it or
not that's the administration's thought
process we'll see how it all works out
unfortunately Republicans do not have
the votes in the Senate for congressman
Bob Goodlatte bill which I believe is
much better it's ridiculous that the
Senate's not embracing that so what the
president did is he actually moved
toward the middle in this immigration
compromise again not where I
be that but I'm just telling you the way
it is when he did that he enraged his
supporters and he perhaps even risks his
own reelection by doing that so think
about that he did all that and what are
the Democrats saying in reaction let me
just say when I said last night that
plan is a campaign to make America white
again if you start putting in all of
these highly charged toxic issues it's
just not going to work I don't even know
what that comment Matt but these people
are total fanatics they are fanatical
for open borders an endless migration of
low-skilled labor purely for political
purposes and we didn't even tell you
what Chuck Schumer said yet now as I
said earlier this week Democrats believe
that they have to repeal and replace the
American American electorate who voted
for Trump and continued to vote for
Republicans nationwide they have to get
rid of those voters or at least swamp
them with new voters so Nancy Pelosi and
Schumer Durbin etc they have to keep
their grievance aasaiya tea growing and
their identity politics racket going
they have to do this they believe in
order to win elections in the future
because otherwise what are they going to
say the economy's thriving country is
doing really well they have no ideas I
think they're out of the ideas business
altogether all they believe in is
division identity politics the blame
game calling Trump a dictator that's all
they have and if this all means by the
way this immigration view that they have
if it means like lowering the standard
of living for the average working person
the average citizen by allowing in all
these new low-skilled workers will
so--but and for the Democrats if that
means continuing to resist Trump even
when its policies are actually
benefiting Democratic voters so--but I
am telling you these people are
dangerous fanatics and it is they not
President Trump who end up destabilizing
and destructive forces in the body
politic he's exposed
them like no one has before and that's
the angle